[Music]
i would like to learn about duck calls
i'd really i think we could all learn so
why don't you give me just a quick
starter
who brought your very own duck call
right there listen i'm going to he's
going to teach you how when you hear me
call you come back and do the same thing
i do okay now these mating calls are
these uh is this is this the no no
between us i mean is this like
look five or six which end i have no
idea i have no idea
okay look here hold it like this pull it
like this yeah like like this okay now
look this is these fingers here fine
tuners yeah these are the final chairs
say 10
say 10 right now tem 10
how many times did your tongue hit the
roof of your mouth
one ten ten ten count them
ten it's ten
ten
how many times two okay
there we go
[Applause]
i love you john i really do look here
look it was harvard driving school
what you're going to do is you're going
to basically say 10 cause look
pressure
so i'm going
[Laughter]
five times that's fantastic say ten five
times
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen
ladies and gentlemen
we have operator problems
but you have to maybe my duck is a
little different
maybe i want to get the weird ducks
hey i've been in l.a for about three or
four hours now i just looked around
there's a whole lot different stuff
going on around here you saw her
but look so look a feed call
[Applause]
that's a duck that's a duck feeding oh
that's what they sound like when he
feels like it's sort of giggling in a
microwave you know
oh
[Applause]
i'm the louis armstrong of duck calls
i'm the miles davis of ducks hey check
this out the band is like that cat's on
a whole new level hey check this out
yeah the back of your throat the people
in louisiana you open your mouth real
wide and you look in the back of your
throat now we have i don't know whether
you're doing that but i'll open my mouth
real wise
he's got one
there's a little round piece of meat
hanging down i just see him
it sounds nasty but it's not uvula so
look to do a pin tail
if you don't flutter that pin tail if
you go
that's heavy equipment backing up see i
won't call it up
but i'm going
you can do it
no microbes no microbes i don't care man
i'll swap spit with you any day
[Applause]
flutter you now let you put your finger
on the end of it put your finger right
here and now go
a little harder
okay
weird
madness i didn't realize
it's like anything else i had no idea
there was so much to it it's a weak
start listen you can do this
he was good i thought i was pretty hated
you said willie you were good yeah what
did i mean weak start i think i blew the
roof off this place
how do you know there aren't ducks
settling all around warner brothers
right now
you're the only man